welcome back are you ready to sell
what's the right way and price your home
should be listed for to sell it quick
Kirby Scofield from Schofield Realty the
sponsors of this next segment are here
with the answers welcome to the show
thank you thank you thank you how should
you price your home you ready to sell
how do you how do you how do you price
it to sell
there you go
more thing so one is uh well I was
looking for agents um or scaling so one
would be caller team and then uh we go
off the historical data okay the comps
not what your neighbor's telling you not
what your uh stepdad dad is inspector
comes you do the research yeah we do the
research off the actual values and then
from there uh there's different uh
strategies to use based on what your
time frame is to sell it okay and that's
a big one why would someone want to list
their their pri their home at a high
price
high price if as our Market as everybody
can probably see it has shifted recently
we'll talk more about that next week as
we see what's going with the data but it
is Shifting currently we're starting to
see multiple offers we're also seeing
some stuff go above appraisal again so
if that continues to Trend that way like
it was last year uh you price High
trying to get your magic price okay but
beyond that you price high if you're if
you have the time and you have a certain
price that you think you feel you can
get you just gotta hope that appraises
at it okay if it doesn't appraise then
does that buyer have the difference in
funds to cover it and you're you're the
expert which I love talking to you so
have you been in a situation where a
client says I want to list my home at
this price you're like we need to look
at all the factors around this yeah the
biggest word we had the issue with it
was uh last year right when the FED
raised everything the shift and so we
had 20 plus listings sitting there that
were at those magic prices
it shifted and they just set oh okay it
was the hardest thing to get those
sellers to swallow that pill well now
it's byerson and get them to adjust the
price down to go right so in this
current market you're kind of in a
window where right now if you have a
little bit of time you could go to the
max comps or a little bit higher but if
you want to get multiple offers and sell
it quick actually put it a little lower
to get some buyers there yeah because no
matter what that list price is it
doesn't mean you're green to it so you
can list it say 400 but you really want
420 you don't have to sell it 400. okay
that's just a list just a wiggle room
there you touching this for a second
you're you're looking for realtors right
now 100 yeah we are scaling we have more
clients and homes to sell than I have
Manpower of agents for so so you're
watching right now you're looking to
maybe change your career or you know
step things up you're looking right now
yeah anyone experienced or brand new
okay you're at somewhere and you haven't
got what you got that you needed what we
always say is with two more deals a
month help your lifestyle we can get
that for you okay yeah that's good and
so then you're the ones we trade you're
gonna be training them mentorship
everything I love it this is awesome
thank you so much for joining us thank
you Scofield Realty by the way for
sponsoring this segment for more
information visit schofieldrealty.com or
call call them at
702-941-7202 Las Vegas now we'll be
right back